This event,
this special gathering of the whole
University is a tribute to what all of
you do everyday
to make Harvard, and the world a more
sustainable place.
It's a tribute to the scientific
discovery taking place in our labs,
and in our classrooms
a tribute to the strategists
and the policy architects
who work in our centers and out in the
field.
And a tribute to the leadership
that thousands of you have shown,
by living your lives with an awareness
that each of us has an obligation
to the future
of the planet.
We at Harvard must be a model,
as we demonstrate
our commitment to the future,
as we affirm our belief that the
discoveries of science can enable us to
change the world,
and as we unite the knowledge and
passion of this community
in service,
abroad, and essential goals.
I can think of no better way to
launch our new greenhouse gas reduction
initiative
then with the person,
the nobel prize committee called the
single individual who has done the most
to create greater worldwide
understanding
of what needs to be done to combat
global warming.
Our distinguished alumnus and friend Al
Gore.
(CLAPS)
We teach with what we do, as well
as with what we write,
or what we say.
How we light our classrooms, how we heat
our water, how we build, and
ventalate our laboratories
all send powerful signals.
But some of the most important changes
must take place at the individual
level, in the choices each of
us makes in our energy use
and consumption patterns.
Every person at Harvard student, faculty,
staff,
can contribute to the effort,
to avert the frightening outcomes
that sciences are predicting.
We are all teachers and we are all
learners in this endeavor we must do it
together.